[Music]
uh hello everyone good evening uh this
is Jam Victor meski for the St Louis
chess club uh today we have the lecture
on the uh uh Grand Master's prep and I'm
going to show you uh some of my uh games
where I prepared uh pretty well I
believe and got nice positions out of uh
out of the
opening uh and also the games UHS were
pretty interesting I
believe even though I'm going to show
the games with a good opening
preparation the first game is like an
introductory uh because uh it wasn't
really an opening preparation so I'll
show this game uh really quick uh but it
was interesting uh uh for the next game
I'm going to show you because it's going
to be the same opponent so I played this
game against an international Master
Alex
rabinovic uh with the white
pieces and the game started like
this so in this line black is taking the
C4 pawn and trying to keep the uh sorry
the C4 Pawn with his B
Pawn and and uh White simply goes on
with the
development Bishop B7 A4 Knight
D7 Knight C3 and here he played
B4 uh not not a good move in this
position because black weakens his Pawn
structure on the queen side and why I'm
showing you this game is that uh after
the game uh we discussed we discussed it
and I said that the best move is to play
A6 instead of B4 and that's what he did
in the next game which I'm going to
show right in that game it was already a
good opening preparation in this one
there was not much preparation but the
game itself was kind of
nice he played
C5 Knight
E5 so black has some problems with the
development especially development of
the king side uh white also has a threat
already of Knight takes F7 and after
King takes there is a discovered attack
on the
bishop so uh he played Bishop D5 to keep
the bishop
protected right so what do you think
happened after the move Bishop
D5
any
ideas takes F7 maybe yes and after King
takes King Knight G5 right the king
moves back to e and idea was to play
something like E4 and then Queen
G4 okay very good so that that that's
basically the idea Knight takes
F7 uh A P
sacrifice black has to accept it of
course King takes Knight G5 check uh now
it's dangerous to go to E7 because white
plays
E4 if the bishop moves back indeed you
can go uh Queen
G4 which you
mentioned right and it's difficult to
protect the6
pawn and if black plays H6 intermediate
move white can just take black takes and
now something like Queen E2 is very
strong basically black is in trouble in
this position
so he tried King to
E8 now I played
E4 Bishop
B7 Knight takes E6 now we can just take
the pawn right away Queen B6 and the Qui
move
D5 and it turns out that in this
position uh black is already in trouble
the Knight is extremely strong on E6
white also has a very strong Pawn Center
also z f Pawn is ready to join
Black's position is extremely dangerous
white also is ready to play A5 at some
point maybe even right away so black
decided to play A5 on his own and then
E5 white can also start with the four
and then
E5 so black played Knight to
E7
F4 Knight F5 I'll show you this game
briefly because it doesn't have anything
to do with the open
preparation the bishop goes to E4 it
turns out that if he puts the Knight on
D4 then Queen H5 is coming
and it's a very strong attack for
instance King E7 D6 King takes check
check and white wins
easily uh so after Bishop E4 he played
Knight to
H6 and then uh White can just go with a
development Bishop E3 G6 Queen F3 white
has a lot of time in fact because
Black's black is extremely passive all
of his pieces are
bad he played Knight F7 Rook a D1 so
first of all white brought all of the
pieces into play Rook B6 and now just
D6 now white is ready to something
decisive Bishop h 6 Bishop D5 trying to
improve the position even
more Knight d8 and this is already the
decisive mistake but the position was
lost anyway so I just played Knight C7
check the d8 square was taken by the
Knight so the King has to go this way
and then F5 decides
again Bishop takes Queen
takes Queen H6 Checkmate is coming so he
played H6 and then takes King G7 now
Rook F7 check not the only way to win of
course but uh this the firstc win Knight
takes Knight E6
check the king went back to G8 if the
King goes to G6 then Queen E4 check and
Checkmate played King G8 then G takes F7
check King takes F7 and now a check from
F3 the point is that the King cannot go
to e in view of Queen H5
Checkmate and uh if the King goes to G6
then check on G4 and black gets
checkmated so this was just the
introduction and the um next game
against the same opponent occured later
same year it was back in
1999 uh and uh he played a similar line
against
me so this time uh he knew that the move
B4 is not that
great and so he played A7
A6 that's the main line here Knight goes
to
E5 he played Knight
E7 black can also start with Knight
takes E5 and only after d takes E5 uh I
believe he can still play Knight
E7 or even Queen C7 another option in
this
position but he played the immediate
Knight
E7 and uh here I prepared a a very
interesting idea not necessarily the
best move in the position but after this
move it's very difficult for black to
defend so try to guess uh White's move
here
okay there is a suggestion of playing f
four supporting the
Knight do of duck says D4 what do you
mean under D4 D5 or
what or
E4
okay there is also a suggestion of
taking the F7
Pawn what do you think about this
move is there any compensation for
white looks crazy
right but in fact this is a move I
prepared for the game
so white is just giving up the Knight
for a
pawn okay it was funny because in the
previous game I also sacrificed my
knight on F7 against the same
opponent and I kind of invited him to
play this line with A6
right and when I played Knight a F7 in
this game he started thinking even
though he has only one move
available right so it was like a shock
for him that it's once again Knight
takes
F7 So eventually he
took and then uh there there is nothing
immediate for white in this position but
because of this uh Knight on A7 it's
kind of difficult for black to develop
and obviously the king is also going to
be
weak so what what was the idea behind
the
sacrifice
94 94 that's
right so the Knight is coming to
G5 and uh I want to put pressure on both
F7 E6 right the king will get under
attack and it's not easy to protect the6
Pawn
right so black played King to G8 which
is one of the possible moves in this
position there are other options for
instance uh black and try Knight F5
white can still play Knight G5 check
after King G7
E4 and it's again not so easy to protect
E6 for instance if the Knight goes to D6
Queen G4 is
strong black can try playing
H6 then e takes F5 H takes G5 check on
G5 and Rook
E1 and still some attack for
white or let's say the Knight can also
go to G6 instead of F5 then check King
G7 and Bishop H3 and once again it's
difficult to protect the pawn on E6
there are also other options but Le
let's go with the
game uh black plate King to
G8 avoiding the check on G5 that's
obviously the main
idea so what should white uh do
next
okay Bobby suggests playing Bishop to H3
attacking the6 Pawn immediately in this
case I believe black uh will probably
try to protect with Knight F5 to just
block the
diagonal uh I was asked what if black
plays H6 instead of King G8 but in this
case there is also Knight D6 check right
and black loses a
bishop so King J does make
sense
okay everyone wants to play Bishop H3 so
let let's have a
look or Knight D6 another
option neither of them was played by the
way so in case of Bishop H3 Knight
F5 now if white plays Knight to G5
targeting the pawn on E6 black can play
Queen F6
E4 the knight uh cannot move by the way
there is a nice line and if the Knight
takes white can just take and black gets
checkm uh but instead black can just
play the intermediate
H6 attacking the Knight and now for
instance Knight takes E6 Queen takes E6
Bishop takes F5 and queen
F7 in fact after Queen F7 maybe we can
try Queen G4 but then Knight F6 is
coming with the tempo
so it wouldn't be that
clear okay so let let's go
back Knight G5 so yeah indeed I played
Knight G5 right away so now black is
unable to protect the pawn on
E6 right and so he played Knight to F6
and now a move like Knight F5 would be a
mistake because of the move
E4 black doesn't have the intermediate
move H6 and V of Knight takes and then I
can just take the
Knight and if the Knight moves back then
Bishop H3 is coming and it's very
unpleasant um so he played Knight to
F6
this was this was still part of my
preparation and white has another strong
move
here by the way we didn't have a look at
the move Knight
D6 uh but in this case BL can just play
for instance queen
beat
and the white doesn't seem to achieve
that
much there are still some ideas but it's
not entirely
clear okay anyway let's come back to
Knight
G5 and Knight
F6 what's the best way to continue
forward
D4 E4 a quiet move so you just want to
prepare Bishop E4
or Bishop H3 I
mean or I playing E5 okay but if you
play E5 black will play Knight F D5 a
nice Square for the Knight also E4 maybe
they'll cover E6 uh uh with the bishop
that's also an option like Bishop
seed E4 might be not a bad move but I
believe there is a better one Bishop H3
uh if you play Bishop H3 it also looks
logical but black is going to play Play
Bishop see it
anyway right he can still cover the A6
Square so but the idea of Bishop H3 is
correct we just need to start with
something
else just think when Bishop C it will be
impossible a takes yeah so it takes B5
first and then when black takes back
with a pawn we can play Bishop H3 and
then black cannot play Bishop C8 because
the Rook on eight will be hanging so
indeed just a takes
B5 and it turns out that black cannot
recapture the
pawn right so it takes B5 Bishop H3 just
leads to a
disaster E6 cannot be
covered obviously The Rook is
Untouchable in view of the check
mid
and a move like Knight F5 is also not
going to work I believe because of
Knight takes
E6 and this Knight is hanging if Queen
D5 probably Knight C7 is
there and any other move we can also
trade Rooks and take the
knight uh so after the move a takes B5
black played Bishop to
C8 probably not the best move but it's
already not so easy to play with
black I think uh uh maybe the best
option would be to protect the bishop uh
This Way Queen B6 protecting the bishop
and preparing to
recapture and in case of Bishop H3 black
still has the move Bishop
C8 white can continue for instance like
this bishop H3 Bishop C8 and Rook takes
A6 black will have to take with a rook B
takes and uh White still has
initiative white is going to get this
pawn
and he will have two pawns for the piece
and still very bad
pieces uh so in the game though black
played Bishop
C so now white can simply take the C6
Pawn B takes
C6 this way white also creates a Str
with Discover It attack on eight
so Rook A7 makes sense to move the Rook
away from this
diagonal so how should white
continue
okay there is a suggestion of playing B4
a very interesting move which probably
has the idea of playing
B5 Knight takes E6 is also one of the
the suggestions in this position
probably it was not in this position
right maybe it was
before yeah now it's impossible and also
Bishop to E3 but I don't like Bishop E3
because black can play Knight D5 right
the bishop simply gets under attack
Bishop F4 Bishop F4 supporting the C
Pawn right with the idea of pushing C7
but still Knight probably Knight F
D5 Ah that's your idea okay you can if
even get the exchange this way yeah but
probably Knight takes C6 Bishop A7
Knight
A7 still uh maybe not entirely clear
like two pieces for The
Rook right so Bishop F4 let's have a
look at this idea Knight F D5 Bishop B8
and say Knight C6 yeah if Rook A8 your
idea was to play C7 I
understand but even this one maybe it's
not yet clear because black is not
forced to take right
so maybe the queen goes somewhere like d
I don't know D something maybe even D6 I
don't and then E4 ah after D6 you're
right then E4 will be strong so we
should go somewhere
else um D7 or A8
maybe so save Queen D7 B H3 yeah Bishop
H3 then Queen moves away or even Knight
C7 may
work
it's still a playable for black let's
say in fact white already has two pawns
for the piece right so if we get one
more Pawn it's even even material wise
it will be
fine and so I just played Rook to
A4 this way white brings The Rook into
play I'm picking up the C4
Pawn black played
H6 finally pushing my knight away from
G5 so Knight to
H3 obviously I don't want to block this
diagonal and come to F3 because I'm
going to lose a C6
Pawn G5
the move makes sense it stops my knight
from getting to
F4 but then just Rook takes
C4 so white has three pawns for a piece
and a better position
now Rook
H7 it's an interesting way uh to develop
the
pieces he's trying to connect his Rooks
on the seventh
rank a very rare
case so how would you
continue
okay there is a suggestion of playing E4
and that's indeed what they did in the
game just to take the center with the
pawns why
not okay there is also a suggestion of
playing F4 and that's indeed also a good
idea and then black can white can answer
G4 with Knight
F2 that's also
reasonable black played A5 so black
wants to play next Bishop to
A6 with a
skure so just Rook to E1 moving The Rook
away from this diagonal Bishop A6 Rook
to
C3 and now Knight
C8 it's very interesting how black
managed to connect all of his pieces now
they all seem to
play right the Rooks are connected
now this bishop is more or less active
on the diagonal
and okay the other Bishop is also open
and in fact black is ready to play
Bishop
B4
with with another
skew so how should white
proceed Bobby Fisher say queen
B3 and Bobby knows what he's talking
about right so indeed Queen B3 was
played because the6 Pawn is uh pretty
weak uh so black played Bishop B4 anyway
he's giving up the A6 Pawn but taking an
exchange Queen takes E6 check and King
G8
what do we do
next it was good to take the A6 Pawn
because now white has a lot of uh P
Pawns in the
center but black is going to win another
exchange so it will be an extra
r
okay there is a suggestion of playing
D5 uh which is a reasonable move I
believe
E5
E5 uh also looks pretty good E5 probably
black is going to play Knight G8
right Knight takes
G5 yeah that's what I played in the game
indeed Knight takes G5
another P
sacrifice and it turns out if black
takes Bishop takes
G5 the Knight on F6 is
spinned so what is black going to do if
he plays Rook F7 then
E5 and if he plays Bishop E7 protecting
the Knight then
C7 trying to disconnect between black
species
if say he takes the D4 Pawn trying to
keep the Knight
protected white has a nice tactical
trick Bishop
F1 say queen
D6 and then just Bishop takes F6 check
Bishop takes F6 Queen a check forcing
the king to G7 and then E5
a lot of tactical ideas for white in
this
position and uh black is completely lost
here right Rook G5 check is
coming that's just one of the possible
lines let's say after Bishop F1 black
can also try Bishop takes
F1 but then Bishop takes F6 check Queen
takes F6 and queen takes seed and white
is also completely winning with this
Pawn on
C7 and finally if black plays Bishop B7
trying to keep the bishop on this
diagonal and keep the Knight
protected then Rook D3 is strong
bringing the Rook to
d8 so if the queen moves away then also
the Knight on F6 is hanging and Rook d8
is coming and in case of this
intermediate move Rook
A6 white can simply
take and then the Queen is
hanging uh so after Knight takes G5 he
played Bishop takes
C3 he goes with the material right B
takes and now it's uh as I mentioned in
case of H takes there is Bishop G5 after
Rook F7 E5 and white wins back a lot of
material if you look at this position
white has seven prote it past
pawns you don't see it every day
right so black played Rook H to
G7 and then Queen to
H3 attacking the H6 pawn and preparing
also the move Knight to
E6 black protected with his Rook Rook
G6 then Knight
E6 attacking the Queen the queen had to
move and Knight to
F4 simply attacking The Rook on G6 when
The Rook moves away white gets also the
H6
PA the Knight went back to
H7 and then
the position is of course completely
winning and there are a few ways to play
for
wide
D5 D5 is good yeah yeah so there are
basically many moves I played
E5 why E5 because I also want to bring
my knight my Bishop into
play he played Knight to
E7 in order to play Maybe Knight F5 but
then Bishop
E4 now the bishop is also
coming Bishop
C4 Knight
H5 the Knight is going towards
F6 he tried to give back an exchange but
Queen takes
H7 King takes Knight F6 check the Rook
is
pinned and so I simply uh won even more
material and here he
resigned yeah so here again we have
seven connected past
pawns so six response for exchange not
bad okay so that that's the first game I
wanted to show
you I have one question yes sure in the
second game yes you had all the
preparation in mind uh what what I uh
what they prepared was up to the move a
Tak B5 up to this move so so in this in
this context you want him to know that
you have this already repared by playing
really fast or trying to think in order
to him uh there are different strategies
yes sometimes you can play Just fast and
it also puts pressure on your opponent
or you can uh pretend that you don't
know what to do yeah in this game I
played pretty fast in the opening yes
okay yes and he was kind of shocked by
Knight takes F7 of course which I played
pretty
F uh the next the next game I'm going to
show is a game against Alex shirov a
well-known
player he was even top three at some
point uh the game was played uh in a
recent
tournament uh this summer I played with
the white pieces and prepared the
following line against
him in
z
Bishop G4 that's one of his uh favorite
ways to meet the
a D4 Knight D7 C4
E6 C takes D5 e takes D5 and then Knight
E5 uh this line was played by
yanish against Duda in the last
candidat
tournament and uh White won very
convincingly in that game I can briefly
show you that
game and that game black took Knight E5
probably not the most accurate move
already D takes Knight E4 Knight D2 so
White's idea is that he has a lot of
Pawns on the king
side right which he can uh Advance
pretty fast so Knight D2 Bishop D2
Bishop C5 trying to stop the move F4
which looks very
unpleasant Rook C1 Queen E7 King H2
renewing the idea of
f4 black castled and then G4 Bishop G6
F4 this already looks very unpleasant
for black white has a lot of uh pass not
pass pawns but a lot of Pawns on the
king side H6 Queen E1 Rook f8 Queen G3
Bishop H7 H4 G5 so neomi quickly got a
very good position almost a winning
position already and then played
F5 and uh soon Black's position
collapsed right so he basically won a
piece and uh led the game to a win
without any
problems
so that that was this game was one of
the reasons I prepared this uh line
against Sheriff because it looks
promising for
white uh but uh Alex use the correct uh
reaction after Knight E5 already because
Nom nish's game was played in
2022 so there was some time in the game
and uh uh and so black already know that
the best uh idea after Knight E5 5 is to
play Knight E4 not an easy move if you
don't know
the uh the opening
line and then Bishop takes E4 one of the
possible options for white it's also a
little surprising that white is giving
up his light squared Bishop which is
usually very
strong black plays D takes
E4 and Knight C3 so White's main idea is
to put an immediate pressure on
e4 but black plays Bishop E7 it turns
out that if white takes A4 Pawn then
black has Knight takes D takes Queen
takes D1 Rook takes D1 and Bishop takes
G2 Bishop takes E2 sorry and uh and
black is doing okay in this
position so that's why I first developed
my bishop and supporting the
Knight
of course I'm still in my home
preparation
here so Knight takes
E5 white takes back with the
pawn so black will be unable to support
his E4 Pawn with the F
Pawn and then Bishop
G6 yeah so what's wrong with just
protecting with the bishop
right
Queen to
B3 that was my
idea so uh black has options of uh Queen
B6 and queen
C8 Queen C8 in fact was uh played in
week Z in 2020 in the game Grand Delio
skimer and black even won that game but
White's play in that game can be
improved it was Queen C8 Rook a C1 short
Castle King H2 Bishop F5 and so on and
uh I think white got an advantage but uh
eventually lost the
game right so uh but the move Queen B6
played by Sheriff is better I
think of course the idea is very simple
to protect the B7 Pawn
right Rook F2 D1
that's an important move which doesn't
let black castle Yeah if black castles
The Rook can get to D7 with a double
attack on E7 and
B7 okay this might be also a point uh in
the chat no not easy to defend without
Queen yeah so sometimes it's indeed
easier to defend without Queens on the
board uh and so black did trade Queens
Queen takes
B3 a takes
B3 and played Bishop
F5 and the only this move was new for me
okay I prepar it up to here and looked
mostly get the move
A6 in this position which has a point of
freeing The Rook from defense so black
can go Rook
D and it's probably a better try A6 so
he played Bishop
F5 okay his idea is to uh attack my Pawn
on H3 with a Tempo and after as a move
G4 go with a bishop to
E6 and exchange his Pawn on e4 which was
under attack uh for my Pawn on B
E3 so I simply uh took Knight takes
E4 and he played H7 H5 an intermediate
move before taking the pawn on
B3 obviously I shouldn't allow him
taking the pawn and so I just
played
F3 yeah obviously these days you you
prepare with engine Bobby
um and now black takes Bishop H black
takes first H takes G4 and then Bishop
takes
B3 and it may seem that black is doing
fine in this position he has two Bishops
no real
weaknesses um but after Knight D6 check
Bishop D6 Rook D6 his King is uh not
entirely safe even though this an
endgame
position but in fact the opposite cor
Bishops only help in the
attack yeah and th this will be uh
Black's problem throughout the game his
King he played A7
A5 Bishop to G5 so black is ready to
play A4 to protect his a PA and then he
can play Rook to
d8 so that's why I'm playing Bishop G5
in
advance
A4 and King to
F2 bringing the king closer to the
center one of the ideas might be even
playing like this
E4 if black plays Rook H2 check and
takes the pawn at the end white will
have Rook H1 which which is very
unpleasant so black simply
castled E4 so white has white still has
a lot of Pawns on the king side and
black Black's
King looks uh not very
safe yeah if white manages to play let's
say like this King to F4 it will be a
very scary position and so indeed black
played Rook to
A5 as it was mentioned in the
chat Rook A5 attacking the E5
Pawn by the way it would be probably
more accurate to start with the move
Rook F2 e but it's not so obvious so
Rook A5
F4 and then an inaccurate move Rook to
B5 even though it has a point black
wants wants to play Bishop to
C2 and attack my B2 Pawn or even Bishop
E6 sometimes in order to take this one
with a check while attacking the G4 Pawn
with a
bishop so what should white do
now
yeah there was also a suggestion of
playing Rook to C5 that's also
interesting move which I consider it in
the game Let's briefly have a look
before coming back to this position in
this case white can play Rook to
D7 even ignoring the threat of Rook
C2 Black's best option is Rook to
E8 King to
G3 B5 saving the B Pawn First Rook E1
the idea of Rook eight might
be um I'm not even sure frankly but uh
the idea was mainly to avoid Bishop E7 I
believe so B5 Rook E1 it's not a very
obvious line uh which is given by the
computer F5 Rook B2 and Bishop
B7 and the idea is to create an attack
here while the Bishop is uh stopping all
the past Pawns
I'm not sure I would play like this with
white but computer says it's pretty
strong here if say Bishop C4 even the
simple Rook
A1 and white white can try to slowly
Advance his King side
pawns anyway let's come back to the game
where black played Rook to
B5
um I was thinking I don't know if it's
correct Rook H1 yes the IDE Rook
H6 yes I consider this idea as well so
you sacrifice the Rooks then you want to
put your Bishop on F6 and check mate
with Rook takes
H6 yes there there was a similar
suggestion in the chat as well uh so
let's say if we play Rook to
H1 um I believe uh the possible defense
against this ad is Rook e then if you
play Rook H6 G takes Bishop F6 and Rook
E6 oops sorry not Rook e Rook to E6 and
after Rook takes Rook takes
F6 and black is up a piece
basically yeah that's what I didn't like
about this idea but it's still nice
yes
it's not easy here to find the best move
I also didn't find it in the
game so uh the best move in fact is Rook
to
D2 so simply covering the B2 square and
preventing the move Bishop
C2 and trying to slowly improve the
position right maybe next white can
consider Rook H1 already right at some
point we can
even uh think about this idea right King
moves away from the second drank and
Rook D2
H2 um in this case probably uh black
should play Rook e in case of the move
F6 we can simply trade and move back and
this is a better position for white if
black plays Rook E8 then for instance
King to
G3 Rook B4 attacking the E4 pawn and
Rook E1 simply PR protect him and then
next white can even go with F5 because
Rook E5 will be impossible check and
Checkmate right so white is advancing
his King side pawns
again in the game I played Rook C1
instead of Rook D2 which had a similar
point of stopping the move uh Bishop to
C2 um and here uh he committed a mistake
he played Bishop to E6 even though it
was part of his plan one but uh this
move turns out to be
inaccurate he should have played Rook E8
instead which is not completely
obvious right so Bishop
B6 and then I played Rook to D2 again
protecting the pawn on
B2 and Bishop takes G4 probably another
mistake once again black should have
played Rook eight okay one of the ideas
behind this move is to stop Bishop from
getting onto this
diagonal even though a move like Bishop
B7 can be also considered here because
the bishop is again
Untouchable Rook d8 Rook
H1 uh but he played Bishop takes
G4 yeah he wins the pawn but uh now uh
the G file will be open for my Rook so
Rook
G1 the bishop goes to H5 in order to
block the G file by means of Bishop
G6 which may happen for instance in case
of Bishop to F6 right if he goes Bishop
F6 he may uh try Bishop
G6 and that's why in fact I rejected the
move Bishop F6 but in according to
computer it's still very good white can
continue uh with
F5 G takes F6 and the simple e takes F6
the bishop on G6 is
spinned and it turns out that black side
white ID is not really
taken because black takes back and after
Rook takes G6 King F7 and it's not so
simple but rather white wants to play
Rook
D7 for instance he goes go Rook
B4 first of all King F3 protecting the
E4 Pawn Rook
E8 and now this brilliant move Rook D7
and it turns out that black just cannot
defend his King F takes G6 is coming
with some decisive
attack for instance Rook B takes E4 F
takes G6 Rook E3 check King to G2
the only Square to escape is on H1 to
avoid the
checks so if Rook E2 check just King
H1 and Pawn on G6 is also Untouchable
because of F7
check and if black plays Rook to
f8 then white has a move Rook to
H1 with a threat of playing G7 and rook
h8 and surprisingly BL cannot do much
about it the pawn on G6 is again
Untouchable a very interesting attack at
the end game with very limited uh
resources uh so this would be very
strong playing Bishop F6 in this
position but also the move uh which I
played leads to a big Advantage for
white I I played F5 first with the idea
of playing Bishop to F6 or Bishop even
to
H6
he played Rook to B3 his idea is to give
a check on F3 and try to force me to
block the G
file so here's the strongest move uh
would be Rook to D7 again even though
I'm giving up the B2 Pawn with the
check but white doesn't care anymore
about the uh Queen side he just goes for
a direct
attack I have a question how much of
this uh I calculate ahead of time okay
not not that much of course you need to
calculate uh when you achieve this
position right I obviously I didn't know
I going to achieve something like
this so uh Black's best move in this
position after Rook D7 is Rook A8 then
white can play Bishop
F6 Rook F3 check the King goes back to
E1 in order not to block the G file G6
white can just take the B7
Pawn okay it's not not so easy to
understand this
position there
are uh there are a lot of different
ideas I I'll show you the computer first
line C5 King D2 C4 King C2 Rook C8 and
Rook
D7 yeah don't ask me why all of these
moves were
played that's very difficult to
understand uh so in the game I just
played Bishop to H6 which looks like a
more human move just a direct attack on
G7 uh but it turns out that the move is
inaccurate because black had a a very
nice
defense King to
H7 and then if I take the pawn bishop
takes G7 black plays Rook
G8 I cannot play Bishop F6 because of
Rook F3 check and I lose my
rook and uh after the move F6 which
white doesn't really want to play
because
then it will be difficult to break
through there black plays Rook F3
check King E1 check on E3 takes the E4
Pawn white still has the option of Rook
G5 because the bishop cannot move away
then just Rook H2 with a
Checkmate but black plays Rook
F4 after King G to check the king comes
to G3 there are still some threats like
this is
White's ideal position with a check M
but black can in fact sacrifice an
exchange and play Bishop
B6 then he gets back the G7 pawn and
this position should be
defendable so here black uh achieves a
draw if he plays played King H7 but in
the game he played Rook F3 check which
was his idea behind Rook
B3 the King goes to
E1 and now King H7 same idea but a
little late Bishop takes
G7 now he plays some more checks King F2
Rook F3 King E1 Rook E3 King F1 so I'm
avoiding the repetition Rook F3 check
and Rook
F2 I can block the
check and now uh his next move was a
mistake and it could have become the
decisive mistake Rook Rook
G in fact here I saw the correct idea
but uh but just uh played in in the
wrong move
order I saw that white can just take on
F3 Bishop takes F3 and play
six the point is that now the bishop is
Untouchable because I simply promote the
E
Pawn and if he takes the E6 Pawn with
the pawn I play
F6 and then after Bishop H5 simply Rook
H1 King G6 and Rook takes
H5 after King takes F7 followed by f8
and this winning a game for
white and finally if black plays
F6 that's basically the move why I
rejected uh the idea I can simply Play
Bishop takes
F6 Bishop takes
E4 and here I failed to see uh the move
E7 with the idea to meet Rook eight with
is Rook
G5 now it turns out that white simply
brings his King towards F4 and then uh
wins without any problems with two
protected
passers so Rook F3 would win the game
instead I decided I'll better start with
E6 to avoid this line with F6 so now F6
makes no
sense right
and if he takes Rook takes G7 I'm going
to trade Rooks all the Rooks and still
E7 a similar win but what I forgot about
is that he can trade Rooks on
F2 and then take my bishop and it turns
out the Bishop from H5 is covering the
E8
Square so now it's white who needs to be
uh uh accurate and uh escape with the
draw so it was just a blunder in the
time
trouble so here I played Rook to H1
pinning his
Bishop if he plays King H6 white can
play E7 Rook G8 and F6 with a very
strong protected past Pawn on E7 for
instance if King G5 Rook G1 check
followed by
E5 and then uh uh he needs
to uh deal with Rook G4 followed by E6
and why just promotes his pawns so after
Rook H1 he simply took F takes E6 Rook
takes H5 King G8 so we got the Rook end
game I played F6 in order to get a
protected past Pawn again F takes E6 was
also possible
Rook G6 and
E5 so as I said white gets a protected
past Pawn even though black is up a pawn
but the position turns out to be equal
B5 King
F3 if I my move my Rook away then Rook
sorry then Rook G5 is coming with an
attack on E5 so I need to First bring my
king to support the E Pawn The Rook goes
to G1 and now I can bring my Rook
because the king can protect the E5
PA B4 and Rook to D2 activating The
Rook now I have some ideas on the D
file Rook E1 King G4 protecting the E5
Pawn Rook F1 check King
G5 so obviously Rook F5 is a big mistake
because of King
G6 so he played Rook G1 check King F4
Rook F1 and we agreed to a
draw and indeed the position
is uh is
equal okay so the these are the ideas I
wanted to show you
today uh thanks everyone uh for watching
and hope to see you
again so bye for
now
[Music]
he